good afternoon on the professor of
theoretical physics and Dean of the
College of Science and associated with
the chair that I thought is the same
lecture some welcome for this year's
lecture it is the 14 since this series
was restarted in 1996 today's of you
lecture is run to call he was the
founding of head in 1983 of the
theoretical physics group at Fermilab
and in 2004 the founding director of the
particle physics center today he's after
Holly Compton distinguished service
professor of astronomy and astrophysics
and a local the chair of the department
of astronomy and astrophysics at the
University of Chicago in addition to
over 200 scientific papers that flow
from his research on particle physics
history of the very universities the
co-author the early universe the
standard textbook particle physics and
cosmology Rocky's a fellow of the
American Academy of Arts and Sciences
fellow american physical society and the
recipient of the two thousand rupee or
state metal
association of physics teachers and the
1993 quantel control fries for teaching
excellence at the University of Chicago
his vote for the general public glowing
launchers of the stein received in 1996
meo board of the American aeronautical
society now as many of you know rocky
gave a previous lecture and that the
second apertures in 1997 which was
titled primordial soup to Pittsburgh and
during that match our rocky reveal the
can of primordial soup recognize the
label colors but it says fermilab
primordial soup instead on it and then
he handed it to the dead provo so the
morning not to open it because of the
danger that such an act would present
partially I safely remove the cam from
the hands of the provost and abstain
this very day pepper opening it's been
quite a topic of conversation where
rates people visiting my office now
today I wouldn't open it either even
though it's only about a billion
lifetime of the universe later not so
much for the original reasons as the
light bulbs that came much later in the
dispute the others that i might unveiled
by
but there's another reason not to open
it and keep it closed that's because at
the time of the last lecture dark energy
had not been discovered so I suspect
that what's in here has got dark matter
but not dark energy and so I'm going to
keep this can for a universe that never
was with dark matter in it but no dark
energy but after today's lecture I
expected can so to tell us about the
universe and our understanding of it
today and how it will explore it and
understand dark energy and dark matter
we head back by popular demand people
and mysteries of desire
Thank You Fred it's a pleasure to be
back when Fred contacted me and invited
me to give the hbu lecture I would sort
of embarrassingly said but I've already
given one and he said well we want you
to keep giving it to you get it right
and also if you check that can of soup
Fred you'll see there's an expiration
date on the universe this evening I will
talk about mysteries of the dark
universe for thousands of years
astronomers looked up into the sky and
charted the location and apparent
movements of stars but the nature of
stars what they are made of and how they
shine was a cosmic mystery until the
20th century when with the input of
quantum physics astrophysicists were
able to understand what powers the Stars
and what they're made oh why the stars
shine and what they're made of and that
cosmic mystery was solved also at the
beginning of the 20th century
astronomers use new generations of large
telescopes to look beyond the stars in
our galaxy and discover a universe full
of galaxies but the nature of these
extra galactic objects remained a
mystery until the big bang theory
predicted the expansion of the universe
and that cosmic mystery was solved with
the big bang theory as we begin the 21st
century we're faced with two cosmic
mysteries and these two cosmic mysteries
have names but no understanding we have
names for two phenomena that are a
mystery to us one we call dark matter
dark matter is just a name for whatever
it is that's holding galaxies together
we think it's a new type of elementary
particle but it's still a mystery
we have them another phenomenon that is
a mystery to us and that we call dark
energy this seems to be a property of
empty space and energy are a mass to
empty space that drives galaxies and
other structures apart in the cosmic
expansion these are the two mysteries
that are facing cosmologists at the
beginning of the 21st century now I just
last week filled in this little form in
where it said occupation I wrote
cosmologists I don't know if anyone
reads that form but perhaps they think
this person does not know how to spell
cosmetologist but cosmology and
cosmetology are different and the way to
keep them apart cosmetology studies the
universe of makeup and cosmology studies
the makeup of the universe one studies
Big Bang the other big bangs
cosmology thank rich cosmology is one of
the oldest professions there was a
famous American anthropologist George
Murdoch who surveyed every society known
to anthropology broke both historic and
prehistoric societies and when he
realized is that all sis all of these
societies shared some activities that he
described as cultural universals and
among the cultural universals were
religious rituals every society has
religious rituals of some type or
another every society has some sort of
marriage taboos every society it turns
out seems to make alcoholic beverages
every society has some sort of body
adornment so in fact cosmetology is a
cultural Universal also in every society
has had a cosmology every society known
to history and presently today have a
cosmology a view of the universe and
attempt to answer simple questions like
where did the universe come from how old
is the universe what's in the universe
these are simple questions that
cosmologists attempt to answer the aim
of modern cosmology is to not only to
see what's in the universe but to peer
behind what we see in the universe and
to discern how the universe works not
just what's out there and how it moved
between how it moves but why does it
move in that way now in previous times
people had ideas of crystalline spheres
or mechanical gears or other sundry
devices but now we try to understand how
the universe works on the basis of the
laws of nature as I said cosmologists
try to answer simple questions sometimes
the answer is own so simple but the
questions are off
simple and one of the simple questions
is what's in the universe what is the
universe made of it's a question someone
four or five years old could ask the
answer to this question seems to be
surprisingly complicated and we have a
standard model of cosmology today that
seems to explain all of the cosmological
observations but it has a remarkably
complex composition of the universe
today and this composition is best
described in terms of this pie chart and
I'd like to go through some of the
ingredients of the present universe with
you the early universe was dominated by
radiation but today in the cold universe
radiation consists of only about point
zero zero five percent of the mass
energy of the universe this chart also
illustrates why chemistry is not very
important
the chemical elements by which I mean
elements other than hydrogen and helium
comprise only point zero to five percent
of the mass energy of the universe it's
a mystery to me why anyone would invest
time in such an insignificant fraction
of the universe there's a much larger
fraction of the universe in the form of
elementary particles known as neutrinos
a neutrino is like an electron if you
win in with a very small pair of
tweezers and extracted the electric
charge from the electron what would be
left behind is a neutrino neutrinos are
all around us billions of them will pass
through your body during this lecture
you don't feel them stars the
traditional thing astronomers study is
only point eight percent of the universe
most of the normal stuff in the universe
is hydrogen and helium gas that's not in
the form of condensed objects but is a
form of a gas in clusters now the
remarkable thing about this chart is if
we add up all of the things we know
about that we can explain and we
understand it makes up only five percent
of the total mass energy of the universe
there's something holding galaxies
together that we call dark matter that
seems to make up twenty-five percent of
the present mass energy of the universe
and there seems to be something else
that's pushing galaxies apart in the
cosmic expansion we call it dark energy
and that represents about seventy
percent of the mass energy of the
universe ninety-five percent of the
universe today is a mystery to us it's
the mysteries of the dark universe now
this is part of a model of the universe
but what I've learned in talking to my
colleagues and other disciplines is that
what else what a physical scientist at
least means by a model implies by a
model is something different than what
our colleagues in the social sciences or
other areas described as a model for
instance there was a twentieth century
economists to
mostly at MIT and he wrote about models
in economics he wrote that the
construction of a motto consists of
snatching for the enormous and complex
massive packs called reality a few
simple easily managed key points which
when put together in some cunning way
becomes for certain purposes a
substitute for reality itself so
economists have a model and in their
model they don't have anything dark but
they have an invisible hand that's
responsible for taking money out of your
pocket and spreading it around through
the economy now I don't think economists
believe that there are actually
invisible hands but cosmologists think
that there actually is dark matter and
dark energy the question facing us today
is whether dark energy and dark matter
is a substitute for reality itself or if
it is actually part of reality itself
now in terms of forming this
cosmological model that tells us that
should be dark matter and dark energy
it's based upon a theory for the origin
and evolution of the universe and this
theory is the big bang theory we've all
heard of the big bang theory and there
are some people who say that it's just a
theory now as a theoretical physicist I
don't like to hear people say it's just
a theory theories of beautiful things
just because something there's a
difference between a theory and
something that's just wild unsupported
conjecture evolution is just a theory
that doesn't mean everything else is
equally possible or equally probable in
people who say that it is just a theory
we should teach all possibilities I like
to remind them that gravity is just a
theory and when you approach the edge of
a cliff please consider
possibilities but in fact the Big Bang
is more than a theory it's much more
than a theory it is a television program
and this gives it immediate importance
and credence and in fact you know
there's people in philosophy of science
who argue that theories can only be
shown to be wrong you can never prove a
theory right you can never validate a
theory but they never anticipated the
power of the networks and in fact it is
possible to validate a theory and the
Big Bang Theory has been validated so
we'll take it as a fact now the
emergence of the Big Bang Theory our
present cosmology involves something
that previous cosmologies did not it
involves the nature of space and time
and to understand the presence of dark
matter and dark energy we have to
understand something about the nature of
space and time whether we realize it or
not in our everyday actions we operate
in a classical or Newtonian picture of
space and time in Newton's remarkable
book the Principia he wrote about space
and time he wrote that absolute space
remains always similar and immovable and
he wrote about absolute true in
mathematical time which has no relation
to anything external so in the Newtonian
view of space and time space and time or
fixed and physics is played out on this
fixed playing field of space and time so
physicists study velocities through
space changes of things with respect to
time but space and time remain fixed
this view of space and time changed at
the beginning of the 20th century with
the work of Albert Einstein in 1905
while a third class patent Clerk
Einstein looked at
equations he was scribbling when his
boss wasn't looking at him and came to
the conclusion that the way humanity had
viewed space and time for tens of tens
of thousands of years was wrong space
and time are not separate they are in
fact relative Einstein didn't stop there
10 years later while a professor at the
University of Berlin he looked at
equations and came to the conclusion
that the way we have you geometry at
least since the time of Euclid was
incomplete and that space and time are
not fixed in absolute they can be curved
and warped and bent and this concept
that space and time can be curved in
warped and bent was part of his theory
of gravity and only when Einstein
developed his theory of gravity did
cosmology become a science one of the
first applications of Einstein's theory
of gravity that Einstein did was to try
to understand something about the
universe so Einstein's theory of gravity
is the basis that we use to understand
the universe is the basis of the Big
Bang Theory so in some sense Einstein's
equations his theory of gravity are the
modern commandments of Genesis now
everyone is familiar with the one
equation I'll show in this lecture the
Einstein field equations and some of you
are familiar with the fact that it looks
like one equation but actually is a
shorthand notation for ten nonlinear
partial differential equations so it's
sort of the 10 commandments of Genesis
right now a couple of you who are
technically astute with Einstein's
theory of gravity would put up their
hand and say but you only have to obey
six of the equations just like the Ten
Commandments right six
for our optional 6 out of 10 is a pretty
good day for a lot of people so the
technical thing about Einstein's
equations that's important tonight is
that it has a left-hand side and a right
hand side the left hand side of
Einstein's equations describe geometry
in space and time curvature of space
expansion of space that's all on the
left side of the Einstein equations on
the right side of the Einstein equations
is all of the information we have about
matter and radiation and forces how
matter and radiation are distributed in
space what sort of forces are acting on
them that all goes on the right side of
Einstein's equations so Einstein theory
of gravity is based upon the idea that
gravity is related to geometry the left
hand side is the curvature of space that
we interpret as a gravitational field
and it is determined by the distribution
in nature of what's on the right hand
side the matter and radiation in the
universe so in the years nineteen
fifteen to nineteen sixteen Einstein
developed his theory of gravity related
to geometry which is determined by
matter and radiation and it was a simple
beautiful and elegant theory many people
think is the most beautiful theory ever
constructed then Einstein tried to apply
his new theory of gravity to study
cosmology because Einstein was dismayed
to discover that his theory did not
conform to the universe as he thought it
should exist Einstein was educated in
the nineteenth century with the idea
that the universe is eternal it's
stationary it's unchanging Einstein
could not find solutions to his simple
beautiful and elegant theory that
described a universe that was stationary
he could find solutions where the
universe expanded or contracted
but he could not find solutions where it
was stationary so Einstein did something
remarkable in 1917 he added something
that technically we describe as a fudge
factor he added a new turn to his
equations in order to find a solution to
his equations that described a
stationary eternal universe and there
was a constant in this turn he added
that he described as the cosmological
constant so the cosmology of Einstein
which only lasted 12 years depended upon
three parts one is this his theory of
gravity which was related to geometry it
described a stationary eternal universe
and it had this additional term that he
described as the cosmological term I
think that now for the first time in
history cosmology is a science people of
always had always speculated about the
nature of the universe the nature of the
cosmos but now it was based upon a
theory of physics and it had an aspect
that we demand of science it could be
shown to be wrong it could be falsified
and that is what happened when in 1929
the cosmology of the greatest authority
of Sun in science or lease in physics of
the 20th century was shown to be wrong
on the basis of observations made by a
basketball player now not any basketball
player but a basketball player on the
last decent athletic team of the
University of Chicago
of the 1909 national championship
basketball team and if people would ask
me the real difference between Carnegie
Mellon and Chicago is that Chicago is an
athletic powerhouse the forward on this
1909 national championship basketball
team you've heard of his name was Edwin
Hubble in about in less than a month
there is scheduled to be a launch of the
space shuttle to send astronauts up to
repair the Hubble Space Telescope the
astronaut leading that mission is John
Grunsfeld who was who went to the
University of Chicago so when he was
assigned to leave this mission he gave
us a call and said is there anything
that Hubble left behind at the
University of Chicago that I could take
up on the space shuttle to visit the
Hubble Space Telescope and we poked
around and we discovered that basketball
so we shipped it off to John and he
managed after only three months of
arguing to convince NASA to let him take
this basketball up in space and so when
you see television you see you will see
astronauts passing around a basketball
it is a basketball that Hubble played
with in 1909 I don't think he imagined
that basketball would ever be up in
space what who discovered that disprove
the cosmology of Einstein is that space
expands the universe is not stationary
or everlasting or eternal Hubble
discovered that space is expanding
Einstein at first didn't believe the
observations but after only a couple of
years he was convinced so he described
his introduction of the cosmological
constant as his biggest blunder and
returned to his simple beautiful and
elegant theory that he had developed in
1916 another hallmark of science is that
a theory or a motto will make
predictions that one can go out and test
among the predictions of the big bang
theory is the prediction that there
should be a background of radiation that
is a remnant of the hot primordial
fireball this prediction was confirmed
in 1965 when Arno Penzias and Robert
Wilson discovered the hot the remnants
of the Hutt primordial fireball in terms
of a background radiation at a
temperature of three degrees above
absolute zero or minus 270 degrees
Celsius I guess that's something like
minus four hundred and fifty-four
degrees Fahrenheit another prediction of
the Big Bang has to do with the chemical
abundance of the elements now let me
remind you why no one likes chemistry
there are frankly too damn many elements
we don't need all these every high
school chemistry teacher a student I
speak to says wouldn't it be great if we
could study Greek chemistry they only
had four elements air earth water and
fire out of this they can make
everything I tell them that in fact they
should study cosmological chemistry
because we only have three elements in
our periodic table we have hydrogen
helium in anything that's not hydrogen
and helium we just call a metal
chemistry is really simple now we do
this for two reasons one it really
annoys chemists and the other reason is
that 99% of the universe today is
hydrogen and helium only 1% of the
universe that we see today of the
elements that we're familiar with is in
the form of anything that's not hydrogen
and helium so we can get a ninety-nine
percent on chemistry just by having
hydrogen and helium and metals
furthermore we can determine the
isotopic abundances of hydrogen and
helium and 10 to the minus five of the
hydrogen is in a form of heavy hydrogen
known as deuterium and about the same
fraction of helium is in a rare isotope
of helium with only three neutrons and
protons in the helium nucleus we
understand this chemical abundance based
upon what was produced in the Big Bang
that's the first step so three minutes a
be after the bang it's predicted that
the universe would have been seventy-six
percent hydrogen twenty-four percent
helium and it turned out that to make it
through the first day the universe
needed just a little lithium not much
about one part in 10 to the 10 the
abundance of lithium in the three
minutes after the Bang is comparable to
the abundance of benzene in water that
you drink it's a very small fraction
this is the basis of understanding the
chemical evolution of the elements from
this primordial mix of hydrogen and
helium and lithium the first generation
of stars formed and inside the stars was
also hot enough to burn the hydrogen and
helium through nuclear processes into
the chemical elements that we see around
us then those stars exploded enriching
the interstellar medium with heavier
elements so one of the remarkable
conclusions of this picture is that
every atom in your body that is not
hydrogen and helium was once made in a
star so you can either depending upon
your point of view view yourself as star
material
or nuclear waste so that's a brief
rundown of our cosmology today and the
conclusion is that our universe emerged
from a state of high temperature and
density 14 billion years ago and is
expanding and cooling evolving and
dynamic the universe emerged 14 billion
years ago naturally I once when I was
grading a test paper this year and I
asked my students that I teach what is
the age of the universe and someone
wrote 14 billion years in two weeks and
I try to teach them you know accuracy
and what you can say so I marked it
wrong and the student came to me and
said how can this be wrong for two weeks
ago you told us the universe was 14
billion years old
our universe is evolving it's changing
the universe today is different than the
universe of billion years ago so this is
a theory however we can show that this
theory is correct because astronomers
possess something that paleontologists
do not have that geologists do not have
astronomers have time machines we are
able to view the universe in the past we
have time machines these time machines
are telescopes because light travels at
a finite velocity as we look out in
space we're looking back in time for
instance right now the people in the
back of the room look younger to me then
the people in the front of the room
because it's taken light you know the
blight from the people in the back of
the room is emitted Oh 100 nanoseconds
earlier than the light from the people
in the front of the room as we look out
in space we're looking back in time the
farther out in space we look the further
back in time we can see so the universe
to tonight we're looking at the universe
as it exists 14 billion years after the
bang we can look out in space back in
time to see the earlier universe but
there's a limit to how far we can look
out in space in back in time for the
first 380,000 years of the history of
the universe it was so hot and dense
that light could not travel through it
it was opaque so there is a limit we
cannot directly look back in time
earlier than 380,000 years after the
bang so I'll talk about ways we can look
back to the hot primordial soup but we
can't do it directly
now let me turn to the idea of dark
matter when we look at a galaxy we can
determine the mass of the galaxy in two
ways in at least two ways one way we can
determine the mass of a galaxy is just
by seeing how bright it is if we see how
bright the galaxy is we can get a good
estimate of how many stars there are in
the galaxy we understand the masses of
stars so we can weigh a galaxy determine
its mass by seeing how bright it is we
can also determine the mass of a galaxy
by measuring how rapidly it spins the
thing that's holding the Galaxy together
is gravity from all of the mass of the
galaxy the faster the galaxy is spinning
the more mass has to be there producing
the gravity holding the Galaxy together
now if we compare the mass of a galaxy
that we deduce by seeing how bright it
is with the mass of a galaxy that we
calculate by measuring how rapidly it
spins we discovered something that we
refer to as in accounting irregularity
the numbers do not agree it doesn't add
up something's missing we need a bailout
a recovery the bailout in this case is
dark matter there has to be more mass in
the galaxy keeping it together then we
can see in the form of stars or anything
else that we can determine this was
really demonstrated in the late 1970's
and early 1980s by the work of the great
American astronomer Vera
rubin in what she did was to measure the
velocity of stars in the galaxy in our
galaxy and distant galaxies and graph
them as a function of the distance of
that star on the center of the galaxy
based upon the estimate of what we see
how much mass is there and what we see
we would expect the curve to look
something like this but in fact the
observations do not agree with what was
expected just on the basis of what we
see so there must be more to the galaxy
than we see and this is what we call
dark matter so when we look at a galaxy
we're seeing only the tip of the iceberg
most of the matter is dark and it
doesn't seem to be normal matter now we
don't see Dark Matter directly but we
can ask a computer to tell us what a
galaxy would look like if we could see
dark matter and the computers should
tell us that in fact a galaxy if we we
would see all of the mass not just the
visible mass this is what a galaxy would
look like there's a disk in the center
which comprise the galaxy that we do see
the visible thing but it's surrounded by
a halo of dark matter that's dense in
the center of the galaxy then the
density decreases as you go far away
from the center of the galaxy
furthermore we expect there should be
clumps of dark matter that we don't see
in this galaxy so we only see the tip of
the iceberg we only see the central
bright part of the galaxy it's
surrounded by a halo of dark matter what
is this dark matter what is the glue
that's holding galaxies together what
are what is the missing piece that we
don't see well there are various ideas
one idea is that Newtonian dynamics
mix or our theory of gravity is wrong
and dark matter is not there but somehow
our theory of gravity is wrong on
Newtonian dynamics is wrong recent
observations suggest that this is not
the answer then there's the idea that
the dark matter is normal stuff but it's
concentrated in some astronomical
objects that are difficult to see like
planets maybe our galaxies just full of
planet sized chunks of rock or objects
that used to be called dwarf stars but
in fact now particularly at universities
they are referred to as size challenge
stars sighs challenge stars are also
light challenge stars they would be very
dim maybe our galaxy is just full of
stars that have maybe one to five
percent of the mass of the Sun another
possibility that's discussed is that
most of the mass of our galaxy and most
of the mass of the universe is in the
form of black holes which do not emit
light that we can see these ideas for
dark matter are grouped under the name
of massive astronomical compact halo
objects or machos so one idea is that
the universe the mass of the universe is
dominated by machos observations suggest
that this is not the answer and the best
answer today seems to be that the mass
of the universe is in the form of a new
type of elementary particle that has a
mass and it's very weakly interacting so
it's known as a weakly interacting
massive particle or a wimp who could
have predicted that wimps dominate the
machos wimps seem to be today the best
explanation for this phenomenon that we
refer to its dark matter
so let's explore the idea that the dark
matter is a new elementary particle or a
wimp this wimp would have been produced
in the first second of the history of
the universe this is the theory but
again we have to find evidence to
support this theory to see whether it's
right or not but recall we can't look
out in space back in time to see the hot
primordial soup because the universe was
opaque we can't see through it so we
have to do something else and what we
can do is to reproduce in the laboratory
the conditions of the hot primordial
soup we make the primordial soup in the
laboratory at particle accelerators such
as Fermi lab which is today at least for
the next couple of months the most
powerful accelerator the most powerful
time machine because it recreates the
conditions in the universe earlier than
a second after the bang and it is in
fact a telescope because it allows us to
look back in time therefore out in space
and so the product of Fermilab is the
primordial soup and my friends the
experimentalist spend countless hours
trying to discover the ingredients of
the primordial soup and they discover
all these ingredients like gluons
photons croutons all these other types
of ingredients in the primordial soup
there's one ingredient that they're
almost positive is there that they're
looking for and this is known as the
Higgs boson
and they expect to find it any day and
it's a big secret at Fermilab whether
the Higgs boson has been discovered
whether there's any glimpse of the Higgs
boson now if you promise not to tell
anyone right that's just between us
there is evidence for the Higgs boson at
Fermilab it's very massive but not yet
Higgs boson but if wimps are the answer
then there should be a secret ingredient
in the primordial soup and this secret
ingredient is dark matter
experimentalists a sorting through the
debris of the collisions at accelerators
looking for evidence of dark matter if
it was produced in the primordial soup
of the Big Bang we should be able to
produce it in the primordial soup at
accelerators perhaps Fermilab does not
have enough energy to produce the wimp
but there is a larger accelerator that's
coming online sometime this summer at
CERN in Switzerland known as the Large
Hadron Collider it's not actually yellow
that is a outline of where it would be
under the Ural Mountains and to give you
an idea the size these are the Alps back
there and this is the Geneva Airport
perhaps the discovery of the secret
ingredient of the primordial soup the
discovery of dark matter of the wimp
will be made in Geneva and not in the
u.s. there are other ways to test this
idea that the dark matter is a wimp if
it's around today then they should be
all around us passing through us
occasionally they should just nudge an
atomic nucleus giving it a very small
recoil now nothing that we can feel but
if you have an ultra pure material
that's ultra code deep underground
shielded from cosmic rays perhaps we can
detect the evidence of the relic wimps
and there are experiments around the
world looking for this another
possibility is that the wimps are
accumulating in the center of our galaxy
where we expect the dark matter density
to be large and annihilating producing
some strange signal that we can see with
telescopes are satellites so there are a
raise of satellites today studying the
galactic center there are gamma ray
telescopes on earth looking toward the
galactic center trying to detect
evidence of the annihilation of wimps so
this is a particularly exciting time in
this field because the race is on to
discover the will to discover what most
of the mass of the universe is comprised
of there are experiments underground
there are gamma ray observatories in
Namibia and remote parts of the US like
Arizona looking up to see tour the
galactic center to see the annihilation
of wimps producing gamma rays Fermilab
is looking for wimps this is a picture
of a detector at CERN that will be
looking for wimps there are satellites
in space and that satellites that have
been launched looking for evidence of
wimp annihilation the race is on
scientists are very excited because we
feel that we're right on the verge of
discovering the nature of the mass of
the universe and understanding and
solving the mystery of dark matter but
there's more to the dark side than just
dark matter and it goes back to the idea
of Einsteins cosmological constant
remember this story in 1917 Einstein
proposed the cosmological constant in
1929 disc hub Oh discovered the
expansion of the universe and the reason
Einstein originally proposed the
cosmological constant
went away so Einstein called the
introduction of a cosmological constant
my biggest blunder he didn't anticipate
that 64 years later astronomers would
find evidence for the existence of the
cosmological constant so the lesson here
an important lesson never admit you're
wrong if Einstein had not admitted he
was wrong he could have been famous
Einsteins cosmological constant if it is
the answer to the observation is the
unbearable lightness of nothing it
implies that empty space by itself has a
mass of 10 to the minus 30 grams in
every cubic centimeter this is a
remarkable result for two reasons one is
that it's not zero you might think that
empty space has no mass associated with
it it's also remarkable because it's so
incredibly small 10 to the minus 30
grams per cubic centimeter now how have
cosmologists and physicists reacted to
this well we've been hard at work and we
have two great accomplishments returning
to this history of Einsteins
cosmological constant since 1998
cosmologists have reintroduced it but
we've done something incredibly
difficult imaginative and clever we have
gotten together and we've lifted up this
term and moved it all the way to the
other side of the equation that is
scientific progress
we've also developed a completely new
and sexy your name for it instead of a
kooky cares about a conscience just
another constant now we call it dark
energy doesn't that sound sexier and
more mysterious that is what we've
accomplished in the last decade thank
you now how can empty space by itself
have them have a weight of a mass well
I'm almost finished my next book titled
much ado about nothing maybe one day it
will be a play or a discussion of the
quantum vacuum and this is sort of the
Zen part of the lecture so i want to say
some words about nothing so let's have a
little gin background it's jen so you
can't hear it so for aspects of nothing
nothing matters nothing is something
nothing has energy and nothing changes
let's first go to the idea that nothing
matters if nothing has a mass if there
is a massive space then it determines
the ultimate fate of the universe the
universe began 14 billion years ago last
tuesday and has been expanding know but
if there's only dark matter in the
universe then the expansion of the
universe will slow the velocity the
expansion will slow because gravity will
pull everything back together and the
fate of the universe is either to reach
a maximum size and rika lapse into a big
crunch or to expand forever ever slowing
however if nothing has a mass and dark
energy dominates then the expansion of
the universe will continue forever at an
ever-increasing velocity
the galaxies not only are getting
farther away from us for getting farther
away from us at a fte with a faster and
faster and faster velocity this is why
we have to do astronomy now galaxies are
getting farther away let's do astronomy
now so nothing matters it will determine
the ultimate fate of the universe now
how can nothing be something how can
nothing be something so I ask my
students to close their eyes and think
about nothing some of them are really
good but thinking I went to sleep
thinking of uh thinking about nothing is
hard work I should have thought about
plugging in the laptop so imagine a
region of space that will call nothing
so it has no matter it has no radiation
in it it has nothing and you can imagine
constructing this by taking a region of
space surrounding it by a hollow metal
sphere evacuating it removing all of the
material in principle cooling it to
absolute zero
cooling it to absolute zero removing all
of the radiation but what you can't
remove from empty space you may remember
my password mechanics tells us that at
every point to emerge from the vacuum
existing for a brief instant before
annihilating and disappearing into the
vacuum so if we had microscopic eyes we
would not see empty spaces quiescent we
would see it as a seething froth of
particles and antiparticles coming out
of the vacuum nothing is something and
nothing has energy this should
contribute to the energy of nothing also
contributing to the energy of nothing is
something known as the Higgs potential
energy every point in space has a Higgs
potential energy of two hundred and
forty-six thousand million electron
volts it is this Higgs potential energy
which is responsible for mass of
particles like electrons WS and Z's
another contribution to the energy of
nothing may come from the existence of
extra dimensions my friends who a string
theorists tell me that there are extra
spatial dimensions that's not true I
don't have any friends who a string
theorist but but if I did they would
tell me that at every point in space
there are extra dimensions and these
extra dimensions are wound up really
tight this should be a contribution to
the energy of nothing finally nothing
changes today the cosmic asmo illogical
constant is absurdly small
in a fraction of the second after the
bang it had a reasonable value 10 to the
100 times larger than today and
triggered a phase of the expansion of
the universe known as inflation then
this reasonable value for the energy of
nothing went away to get this absurdly
small value so in fact nothing changes
I've convinced you I think that we have
no understanding of the cosmological
constant but the race is on to discover
something of the nature of the
cosmological constant dark energy only
is apparent in how it affects the
expansion of the universe so we have to
look out in space back in time to study
the expansion history of the universe
and there's a new generation of
telescopes like LSST the large synoptic
survey telescope that's being built
plans for even larger telescopes 30
meter optical telescopes telescopes on
satellites in space studying the
evolution of the universe to quantify
the behavior of dark energy the American
poet Walt Whitman said to me every hour
of the light and dark is a miracle every
cubic inch of space is a miracle
wouldn't it be great to see or
experience a miracle but in fact every
cubic inch of space is a miracle if you
think of the cubic inch of space under
your nose it contains 1,000 photons from
the Big Bang the remnant of the
microwave of the hot primordial fireball
in every cubic inch of space does dark
matter dark energy virtual particles
coming in and out of the vacuum Higgs
potential energy perhaps there are even
extra dimensions in every cubic inch of
space every cubic inch of space is
indeed
a miracle so what we've learned about
the evolution of the universe is that
for 14 billion years a universe expanded
cooled and evolved from a simple
formless fog of primordial soup into a
universe of galaxies stars and planets
forms most beautiful and most wonderful
I base these words on the words that
were written in the by Charles Darwin on
Origin of Species he wrote there is
grandeur in this view of evolution from
so simple a beginning endless forms most
beautiful and most wonderful have been
and are being evolved Darwin was
referring to the natural world we see
around us but he could have also been
referring to the universe as a whole so
the takeaway message for you this
evening is that ninety-five percent of
the universe is a mystery twenty-five
percent of the universe seems to be in
the form of something holding galaxies
together something and seventy percent
of the universe is in the form of
something pushing galaxies apart in the
cosmic expansion we have names for these
dark matter and dark energy but naming
is not explaining these are the
mysteries of the dark universe the
mysteries of the 21st century cosmology
I said that I thought modern cosmology
scientific cosmology began with the work
of Einstein and we might wonder what
Einstein would think today that
ninety-five percent of the universe is a
mystery I think he would be happy
Einstein thought the most beautiful
thing is the mysterious to Einstein it
was a source of all true art and science
he thought those who are a stranger to
mystery or as good as dead their eyes
are closed cosmologists today are no
stranger to mystery ninety-five percent
of the universe is a mystery I started
off talking about cosmic mysteries of
previous generations the mystery of the
nature of stars the mystery of the
nature of galaxies today we face the
nature of the mysteries of the dark
universe previous cosmic mysteries have
been solved in our cosmic mysteries than
our mysteries of dark matter and dark
energy will be solved also somewhere out
there there's a child with the genius
courage and imagination to reach up and
connect the inner space of the cosmos
the inner space of the quantum with the
outer space of the cosmos to solve our
cosmic mysteries and more importantly to
discover their own cosmic mysteries
Thank
no answers but we are trying for a few
questions marcg that might suggest that
you talk about drinking and that's 33
that's a good question so the question
is we have we deduce a certain energy of
empty space to account for the
observations of the expansion of the
universe 10 to the minus 30 grams per
cubic centimeter the question is can you
construct a fundamental density of space
from Newt from plants constant or the
constants we know about from the
gravitational constant and the answer is
yes yes we can the trouble is it's wrong
by 120 orders of magnitude this in fact
is the worst example of prediction
compared to observation 120 orders of
magnitude wrong that's why it's a
mystery
Pacific I Simon's make an assumption
that was shown to be wrong some of my
subsidy my Canadian could be equally
bought the speed of light blue crossref
universe where you can console et cetera
okay so I said Einstein was wrong when
he imagined a stationary cosmology and
you ask how do we know that we are not
equally wrong about some fundamental
thing that we think to be self the speed
of light is a constant or maybe the
charge of the electron changes with time
gravity changes with time and in fact
this is these are all ideas that people
are investigating as a possible
explanation of dark energy it could be
that dark energy has nothing to do with
the energy of space that it's a property
of space that we think exists but it's
not sort of the eater of the 21st
century but it's an exciting issue in an
exciting problem to work on because
whatever the solution is the answer is
going to be something fundamental and
wonderful so maybe it's not a
cosmological constant but whatever it is
will be even more interesting than a
cosmological constant so you know out of
desperation we are turning to crazy
ideas for the cosmological constant a
crazy ideas for dark energy
dark energy since so the question is
does dark energy density appear to be
constant over time and that is the 1
billion dollar question this is the
question that we want to know the answer
to is it in fact a constant or is it
something else that's changing with time
and the only handle we have to study
this now is to study how the expansion
of the universe changes with time that
we use telescopes to try to study space
missions and that is the billion dollar
question perhaps the answer to that
question will guide our theoretical
understanding of the nature of dark
energy see there was a question yes sir
so so dark energy provides the usual
explanation for dark energy is that it
provides an energy of space a mass of
space that acts in such a way that it
has a pressure a negative pressure that
pushes spaced apart in the cosmic
expansion that's about all we know about
it whether it's a constant or not we can
only put limits on whether it's related
to a cosmological constant or something
else whether it's gravity that's the
problem that our Einstein did not have
the last word on gravity we don't know
the answer to so the only thing that we
know is that the expansion of the
universe is doing something strange
that's unexpected and we attribute that
to dark energy that's the mystery yes
I'm sorry say again I still didn't hear
it it's 0 entry it was a question about
entropy
so entropy is something that's well
understood in a thermodynamic setting
and measures the disorder of the system
what's not well understood is how do how
to understand entropy when gravity is
included so entropy tells us that's not
your question it was a good answer
though well why don't you see me after
and I'll uh I'll come up with the answer
to maybe the question that you're asking
the implications of finding out in fact
the speed of light is not constant the
implications of the speed of light is
not constant would overturn that one of
the basis of Einstein's theory of
gravity you would yield a new theory of
gravity a new either understanding of
nature a misunderstanding of nature
depending upon your point of view it
would be a profound discovery and it
would it would overturn so many things
it would be great thank
you